und jetzt sehen wir sie dann mit dem
präsidenten ist weiß und dem deutschen
präsidenten steinmeier kränze
niederlegen vor dem alten trauer für die
opfer des olympia massakers vor fünf
sicher
dass beide
staatspräsidenten hier sind wir haben es
schon angesprochen ist tatsächlich eine
sehr sehr bewegender akt und auch ein
signal dass man sehen möchte absolut man
hört ja auch dass die beiden präsidenten
bei der herbeiführung dieser einigung
über die entschädigung eine konstruktive
rolle gespielt haben also isaac herzog
hat vermieden die harte rhetorik der
angehörigen selbst zu spiegeln er hat
immer für entspannung gesorgt und frank
walter steinmeier soll hinter den
kulissen auch viel in bewegung gesetzt
haben er steht bei den hinterbliebenen
in hohem ansehen weil er 2017 bei der
öffnung des erinnerungsortes im münchner
olympiapark der erste hohe deutsche
staatsvertreter war der deutsche
verantwortung zumindest angedeutet hat
hier sehen wir sie noch im stillen
gedenken
man hatte den eindruck in der in den
verhandlungen über die entschädigung
dass die stadt münchen und der freistaat
bayern ganz froh waren dass der bund da
die verhandlungsführung hatte also
sowohl herr söder im a10 als auch reiter
haben sich schon zurückgehalten mit
klaren einlassungen zu dem thema bisher
herr reiter hat schon geliefert auf der
kleinen zeremonie im olympiapark und was
markus söder jetzt zu sorgen hat dass
auch ein spannender
definitiv er wird auch als erster
sprechen beim staatsakt der jetzt
offensichtlich gleich beginnt es gehen
alle in das zelt dass man aufgebaut hat
wie sie schon sagen markus söder wird
als erster sprechen was erwarten sie
sich denn sie sind ja auch ein profunder
kenner der bayerischen politik ich
glaube markus söder hat bisher vermieden
in diese etwas schmutzigen verhandlungen
über die entschädigung hineingezogen zu
werden ich glaube aber schon dass er
weiß was heute von ihm erwartet wird von
den hinterbliebenen aber nicht nur von
denen der freistaat bayern hat die
einsatzleitung damals gehabt in form des
innenministers polo werk das heißt auch
vom bayerischen ministerpräsidenten oder
anhalt klare worte erwartet und ich
denke das jahr sprecher
einsatzleitung es war ja damals auch so
das bis zum schluss nicht klar war wie
viele terroristen
eigentlich hier waren deshalb hat man
auch viel zu wenig scharfschützen
positioniert
getroffen war so die militärische regeln
das auf einen terroristen zwei
scharfschützen kommen müssen man hatte
fünf scharfschützen den fürsten für
buches mal acht terroristen
man hätte wissen können dass es acht
terroristen war was sie hat zudem
hubschrauber umgehen aber die
information hat irgendwie nicht das dem
olympischen dorf in den fliegerhorst
geschafft dass ein gutes beispiel für
die dramatischen pannen ist dieser nacht
jetzt sind mittlerweile die meisten im
zelt angekommen und wir erwarten jeden
moment dass der gedenkakt beginnt
glauben sie tatsächlich dass an die
spitze jetzt hier eine persönliche rede
halten wird oder wird sie auch den
deutschen sicherheitskräften noch die
leviten lesen
ich glaube sie kann jetzt nicht alle
vorwürfe diese auch zu recht erhoben hat
in den letzten jahrzehnten komplett
vergessen sie wird wahrscheinlich auch
darauf hinweisen oder hätte zumindest
das recht dazu der ton wird anders sein
und viele der offenen fragen die die
angehörigen haben kann er jetzt diese
historikerkommission aus deutschen und
israelischen historiker erklären die in
aussicht gestellt wurde vom
bundesinnenministerium und die
steinmeier heute wahrscheinlich
ankündigen wird darf es spannend sein ob
diese fragen alle zur zufriedenheit der
angehörigen beantwortet werden aber
darüber werden wir erst in ein zwei
jahren sprechen können wenn die
kommission gearbeitet hat ein zwei jahre
glauben sie wird das noch dauern also
historikerkommission
brauchen eine gewisse zeit muss jetzt
erst mal ausgewählt und eingesetzt
werden wird sagen dass mindestens ein
jahr realistisch ist aber ich habe keine
verlässlichen angaben dazu
dann erwarten wir noch den vorsitzenden
des zentralrats der juden herr schuster
und die präsidentin der israelitischen
kultusgemeinde von münchen und
oberbayern charlotte knobloch auch beide
werden noch reden sie haben gestern
denke ich auch eine veranstaltung mit
frau knobloch gehabt wie war denn da der
tenor also von knoblauch ist ja
münchnerin auch eingefleischte und
begeisterte münchnerin und das
interessante an ihr war schon dass sie
trotz des schreckens des attentats und
der aufklärung die natürlich auch sie
fordert dass sie dieses warme gefühl der
heiteren spiele schon auch noch im
gedächtnis trägt uns auch für angemessen
hält sich auch an diese seite der spiele
zu erinnern was durchaus auch eine
berechtigung hat auch in das gedenken
jetzt priorität haben muss weil sie in
diesen heiteren spielen dieser idee das
neue deutschland zu präsentieren
da schon auch der politische und
gesellschaftliche wille ausgedrückt hat
diese junge demokratie auf deutschem
boden zu erfolgen zu führen sehr
umstritten ist ja auch die tatsache dass
die heiteren spiele dann nach einer
kurzen unterbrechung nach dem motto oder
games must go on die spiele müssen
weitergehen
weiter gegangen sind auch das hat an die
spitze sehr sehr hart kritisiert sie hat
gesagt sie war fassungslos aus heutiger
sicht mutet diese entscheidung zynisch
an damals gab es gründe das so zu machen
hans jochen vogel und dem was unser buch
kurz vor seinem tod gesprochen haben hat
gemeint man wollte die terroristen nicht
gewinnen lassen ein abbruch wäre ein
sieg für die gewesen so kann man das
natürlich sehen aber fest steht sie
hätten nicht so weitergehen dürfen wie
sie weiter gegangen sind nämlich
pietätslos ohne konsequente
schweigeminuten ohne konsequenten
trauerflor das boc konnte konnte sich
eine genug dass es weitergeht und dieser
berühmte satz der gamescom vom ioc
präsidenten avery brandes war natürlich
zunächst einmal einsam was hat seine
entscheidung mit der viele sportlerinnen
und sportler haderten
danke schön herr deininger wir werden
uns nachher nochmal unterhalten nach dem
gedenkakt der jetzt in diesen minuten
beginnt
[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
seele staatspräsident die frau herzog
herr bundespräsident die wir für küchen
bender
der kreis der angehörigen
opferangehörigen heute und der spitze
mit frau spitzer
überschuss der liebe frau knobloch alle
gäste von nah und fern die leute da sind
wir begehen heute ein ganz besonderes
gedenken die 50 jahre olympia attentat
ein gedenken und anerkennung gegen das
vergessen für ein nie wieder
und für eine hilfe und anerkennung von
vielen schmerzen liebe hinterbliebene
liebe angehörige mir ist bewusst wie
dieser tag und die tage zuvor schwer für
sie sind und immer bleiben werden gerade
hier auch an diesem ort an diesem ort
erinnerung an den fliegerhorst
fürstenfeldbruck wo dieses olympia
attentat am 5 september 1972 sein
schlimmes erschütterndes ende fand
vielen dank und respekt dass sie heute
da sind und dass sie ihr gedenken mit
uns teilen
keiner von uns kann nachfühlen was ist
seit dem attentat durchmachen mussten
wie sie es erlebt haben und doch bis
heute immer noch fühlen mit dem
gedenkakt heute meine damen und herren
begehen während gedenken an die opfer
senden auch ein signal wir sagen den
frauen sie sind nicht allein wir fühlen
mit ihnen
wir können das geschehene nicht
ungeschehen machen aber wir können
hinterbliebenen helfen wir werden ihn
nicht trauer leid und trauer nehmen aber
wir können sie unterstützen und wir
können lernen daraus und konsequenzen
ziehen
ich bin sehr froh und dankbar dass der
zum teil sehr kleinteilige und
bürokratische debatte um die
entschädigung für die hinterbliebenen
endlich zu einem guten ende geführt wird
ich fand es nicht unbedingt würdig was
da diskutiert wurde gut dass es jetzt
eine lösung gegeben hat man es sehr
führt momentan
für diese entschädigung ist wichtig den
deutschland trägt dort eine historische
verantwortung
die täter die täter von terrorgruppen
aber es wird trotzdem viele fehler
gemacht als minister weise des
freistaats bayern sage ich auch wir
haben dort fehler gemacht die polizei
damals war nicht vorbereitet auf solch
eine situation die
sicherheitsarchitektur war nicht richtig
ich entschuldige mich ausdrücklich im
namen des freistaats bayern für die
fehler und für die versäumnisse damals
gemacht worden und ich entschuldige mich
auch dass es so lange gedauert hat bis
man darüber redet und bis man eine
entschädigung gefunden hat das heißt
nicht dass es jetzt besser aber wir
haben daraus gelernt noch einmal wir
bitten um verzeihung
dieses olympia attentat 1972 ist auf
ewig mit unserem land verbunden dieses
attentat hat natürlich die welt
deutschland aber auch bayern erschüttert
und es wirkt bis heute nach
es gab wohl kaum in der geschichte
olympischer spiele die auf der einen
seite so viel freude auf der anderen
seite so viel leid die auf der einen
seite so viel lebendigkeit und leben und
auf der anderen seite tod so nah
beieinander haben
diese olympischen spiele 1972 haben so
vieles verändert bayern münchen aber
auch die welt für uns war es damit der
beginn einer entwicklung zur weltstadt
münchen gab es auf bruch dadurch
bauten veränderungen zwar ein großer
sprung den damals bayern und münchen
gemacht hat bis heute kann man das sehen
am olympiagelände wie es genutzt wird
auch im vergleich zu vielen anderen
lieber präsident bach olympischen
anlagen sie werden bis heute genutzt und
hervorragend gemacht
aber diese freude die war die ende der
ehe mit dem attentat von einer sekunde
auf die andere weil das wecke
heute im nachhinein zu beurteilen das
ist die richtige entscheidung war die
spiele fortzusetzen kann keiner treffen
aber fakt ist damals war es tatsächlich
so dass dieser terroranschlag alles
verändert hat die heiteren spiele wurden
beendet und vom traum ein traum
entwickelt haben und hier an dem ort an
dem wir heute sind war dann tatsächlich
der abschluss der ort des grauens die
fotos von damals wenn man sich anschaut
die gerichte schnüren an die luft ab
wenn man fernsehberichte ließ zieht von
damals dann merkt man wie absurd sich
das vorkommt reporter die danebenliegen
einer polizei die schlecht vorbereitet
versucht etwas zu erreichen
ausgebrannte helikopter spuren der
verwüstung und zeichen eines absolut
sinnlosen starb
seit der zeit haben insbesondere die
angehörigen
ihr leben verändert vorgefunden
man fährt zu den olympischen spielen man
will sport erleben man freut sich auf
das feste gemeinsamkeit man wartet auf
den partner auf den vater die mutter und
was passiert dann man hört und sieht die
bilder und erlebt diesen barbarischen
terroranschlag dies war unendliches leid
und daraus wussten müssen wir immer
wieder aufs neue lernen ich darf das nur
für den freistaat bayern sagen für den
ich verantwortung habe nie wieder nicht
nur nie wieder im sinne einer
schwierigen polizei sondern auch mit
einem klaren bekenntnis gegen
terrorismus aber auch gegen die vorstufe
des terrorismus nämlich gegen
antisemitismus nie wieder nie wieder mal
ich gebe ein ganz persönliches immer
wieder gemacht heute schutz versprechen
ab für das jüdische leben in bayern ich
will dass jüdisches leben freier dass
jüdisches leben froh stattfinden kann
und nicht in großen und im kleinen
bedrohtes es gibt auch kleine anschläge
die jeden tag gemacht werden wie man
angegriffen wird auf der straße hätte
die eigene freiheit hinterfragt wird in
der mann angepöbelt wird dies kann und
darf es nicht geben und deswegen ist der
freistaat bayern sehr stark und
engagiert an der seite an der seite der
jüdischen gemeinden überschuss der liebe
frau knobloch ich sage es immer
ausdrücklich ich bewundere ihre arbeit
ihr einsatz vielen vielen dank dafür was
sie leisten und mit welchem mut sie auch
bei uns anderen auftreten herzliches
dankeschön dürfen
zu diesen schutz versprechen gehörte
schutz jüdischen lebens der schutz der
synagogen die finanzierung dazu wäre
eine beauftragten für jüdisches leben
extra eingerichtet wir haben die
holocaust definition anerkannt als
erstes bundesland das eine der wenigen
länder überhaupt und meine damen und
herren ich gesagt das hier ausdrücklich
bestehen auch an der seite des staates
israel es ist mir wichtig zu sagen
man darf
man darf israel kritisieren und am
heftigsten kritisiert israel israel
selbst die lebendigkeit und die
schnelligkeit mit der regierung und
wechseln zeigt dass es dort eine
lebendige demokratie gibt und dass
getickt zulässiges aber so viele
versuchen über die kritik an israel
letztlich antisemitismus zu verbergen
und das darf unter keinen umständen
passieren nicht nur aus historischer
verantwortung sind wir freunde israels
ich kenne viele die sagen aus
historischer verantwortung hat präsident
herzog müssen wir uns verstehen das auch
aber es gibt viel mehr uns verbindet
gemeinsame werte eine gemeinsame idee
von freien leben und wer ist denn in
dieser gesamten region die
ansprechpartner meine damen und herren
für das was wir an freiheit an toleranz
an werten sehen das ist der staat israel
du musst ihnen sagen fand ich es
unerträglich
unerträglich dass präsident abbas bei
einer offiziellen einladung in
deutschland nicht nur unpassende
vergleiche gemacht hat gepöbelt hat dies
muss man und soll man nicht irgendwann
sondern sofort zurück weisen so kann man
sich nicht bei uns benehmen wir stellen
uns da klar dagegen wir stehen zum staat
israel als freunde partner und
gemeinsame verbündete
nur frieden toleranz und weltoffenheit
hilft uns auch den herausforderungen zu
begegnen
denn jeder dieser anschläge beginnt im
kopf
absurde gedanken böse gedanken
überwinden erste tabu spielen werden zu
bösen worden so müssen wir uns auch
gegen hate speech wenden wenn bei einem
extra stellen eingerichtet die es zu
verfolgen und irgendwann werden aus den
bösen worten von einigen zumindest böse
taten und da greifen wir dann ein
umfassendes schutz versprechen dass ich
meine sehr verehrten und dann ist der
heutige tag nicht nur einen tag der
erinnerung sondern auch ein tag das
bekenntnis sonntag der entschlossenheit
intakt entschlossen alle die denken und
glauben sie könnten so agieren oder sie
haben wieder neue chance bei uns nicht
nie wieder
gemeinsam erinnern und gleichzeitig ein
signal für die zukunft setzen herzlich
willkommen in bayern schön dass sie da
sind und danke dass sie mit den
angehörigen zusammen feiern vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die fehler der vergangenheit aber
auch ein klares schutz versprechen für
das jüdische leben in bayern heutzutage
bayerns ministerpräsident ist mit seinem
ganzen kabinett hier vertreten jetzt
folgt frank walter steinmeier der
deutsche bundespräsident
david berger
anton flieger bauer
sehr friedman
josef gutfreund
elisa halfing
josef romano
damit zu schapiro
hat schon
marx lovin
andere spitze
jacobs bringe
große weinberg verehrte angehörige
exzellenzen werte vertreterinnen
vertreter des bundes des freistaates
bayern der kommunen
werte repräsentanten des jüdischen
lebens in unserem land liebe bürgerinnen
und bürger meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren
kamen zusammen um zu bedenken und zu
trauern wir trauern
um zwölf menschen die vor 50 jahren beim
schlimmsten terroranschlag in der
geschichte der damals noch jungen
bundesrepublik auf grauenvolle weise ihr
leben verloren
wir trauern um elf sportler und einen
polizisten
11 jüdische sportler trainer und
kampfrichter die als teil der
israelischen mannschaft nach münchen
gereist waren den großen ambitionen und
großen hoffnungen
alle hoffnung
endete in einem albtraum
acht schwer bewaffnete mitglieder des
palästinensischen terrorkommando das
schwarze september drangen am frühen
morgen des 5 september 1972 vollkommen
ungehindert in das olympische dorf
einnahmen die elf israelische sportler
als geiseln
zwei von ihnen ermordeten sie schon den
quartieren der kanalstraße ein und 30
grausam die neuen anderen
hier in diesem ort an dem die
befreiungsaktion der deutschen
einsatzkräfte
katastrophal scheiterte sie endete in
einem blutbad
11 jüdische sportler waren tot
ermordet in deutschland
ausgerechnet in deutschland
sehr geehrte gäste heute ist ein tag der
trauer des gedenkens und des innehaltens
ich bin zutiefst dankbar dass sie die
familien der opfer heute hier sind auch
dass sie sehr geehrter herr präsident
herz und heute hier und an meiner seite
sind ohne sie alle ohne die angehörigen
ohne die präsenz des staates israel war
mir würdiges gedenken nicht vorstellbar
ich bedanke mich bei allen die in den
letzten wochen dazu beigetragen haben
dass ein gemeinsames gedenken heute
möglich wurde
fährt angehörige wir können nicht
ermessen welches leid
welchen schmerz sie durchlitten haben
wir können nur erahnen was der verlust
ihrer söhne ehemänner väter für sie
bedeutet hat und
immer noch bedeutet wie lebt man weiter
als junge frau die gerade ihr erstes
kind bekommen hat dessen vater nicht
zurückkehren wird
wie lebt man weiter mit den bildern des
von den spuren der mordtat gezeichneten
raums
wie mit dem wissen dass der ehemann oder
vater dort in diesem raum
nach stunden der todesangst erleiden
musste
wie lebt man weiter mit der erinnerung
dass der ehemann nachdem er angeschossen
wurde vor seinen kollegen unter
unbeschreiblichen qualen
verbluten musste wie lebt man weiter
wenn man zwei postkarten aus münchen
erhält in denen der inzwischen schon
ermordete sohn noch geschrieben hat das
alles ganz wunderbar sei und er sich auf
das nachhausekommen freut
ich weiß das leid der schmerz des trauma
sie leben in ihren familien fort bis
heute nichts mehr ist in ihrem leben wie
es vor 1972 war nichts mehr ist es so
wie es hätte sein können und sein sollen
und fünf jahrzehnte
dauert dieser bohren des schmerz liebe
gäste die spiele von münchen
sie sollten ganz anders werden als die
letzten spiele in deutschland die 1936
die die nazis als bombastische
propagandaschau inszenierten und dabei
die olympische idee charme und
skrupellos zu ihren zwecken missbraucht
münchen 1972 sollte ein gegenprogramm zu
berlin unter 36 seien die junge
bundesrepublik wollte sich präsentieren
als
weltoffene liberale gesellschaft
geachtet war und respektiert innkreis
der demokratien und dass sie sich ihrer
verantwortung vor der geschichte bewusst
war und sich zu dieser geschichte
bekannte
ja da war der ehrgeiz heitere spiele zu
präsentieren in einem in deutschland
das pickelhaube und stechschritt hinter
sich gelassen hat
aber da war eben auch die verantwortung
des gastgebers für sportlerinnen und
sportler aus aller welt auch und
besonders für die aus israel
jenem israel das vom ersten tag seiner
existenz bedroht war umgeben von hass
und feindschaft in israel wusste und
weiß man dass der jüdische staat stark
und wehrhaft sein muss in deutschland
waren die sportler aus israel unsere
gäste ihre sicherheit war uns anvertraut
welch riesiger vertrauensbeweis war es
nach dem menschheitsverbrechen der suva
im land der täter
an den olympischen spielen teilzunehmen
unter den athleten und ihren trainern
waren auch überlebende der shoah zu
traurigen und schmerzhaften wahrheit
dieses gedenkens gehört wir wollten gute
gastgeber sein
aber wir sind dem vertrauen dass die
israelischen athleten und ihre familien
in deutschland gesetzt haben
nicht gerecht geworden
sie waren nicht sicher sie waren nicht
geschützt sie wurden in unserem land von
terroristen gequält und getötet
wir in deutschland wir waren nicht
vorbereitet auf einen solchen anschlag
und hätten es doch sein müssen auch das
gehört zur bitteren wahrheit wir waren
nicht vorbereitet darauf dass dieses mal
ausländische terroristen die olympische
idee missbrauchen wurden kaltblütig
und zu jeder form von gewalt bereit wir
waren nicht vorbereitet auf einem
terroranschlag
bewusst inszeniert vor allem im
internationalen fernsehpublikum
damen und herren das bemühen von 1972
deutschland als friedfertige freundliche
demokratie zu zeigen
dieses bemühen scheiterte in münchen
tragisch das olympische dorf
wurde zur internationalen bühne für die
attentäter zu internationalen bühne für
juden hass und gewalt
und genau das hätte niemals geschehen
dürfen
fassungslos stehen wir von einer vor
einem
wahrhaft ruchlosen verbrechen sagte der
damalige bundespräsident gustav
heinemann bei den worten selbst um
fassung ringend
ja es war ein wahrhaft hoch loses
verbrechen aber
meine damen und herren das reicht zur
erklärung der katastrophe von münchen
nicht aus
viele sagten später diese katastrophe
sei unvorstellbar gewesen für die die
damals dabei waren
war das womöglich das alles
beherrschende gefühl aber
hätten wir nicht
gerade wir deutschen hätten wir nicht
wissen müssen dass die idee der
unvorstellbar kite ein denkfehler ist
der furchtbare folgen haben können
unvorstellbar kite
soll vor nachfragen schützen sie lenkt
von der eigentlichen fragen ab warum
konnte das geschehen was niemals hätte
geschehen dürfen liebe gäste wenn wir
heute gedenken
dann müssen wir uns aufrichtig und
wahrhaftig erinnern diese erinnerung das
schmerzhaft und sie ist es vor allem für
sie liebe angehörigen aber sie muss es
auch für uns in deutschland seien die
ereignisse in münchen 1972 haben tiefe
dunkle spuren hinterlassen im leben der
angehörigen das trauma von münchen hat
sich eingegraben ins kollektive
gedächtnis der menschen in israel
tiefe dunkle spuren hat der anlage aber
auch bei uns hinterlassen in der stadt
münchen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland dieses heutige denken darf
kann deshalb nur dann aufrichtig sein
wenn wir zu schmerzhaften einsichten
bereit sind wenn wir uns dazu bekennen
dass die geschichte des olympia attentat
auch eine geschichte von
fehleinschätzungen
von furchtbaren
von tödlichen fehlern ja eines versagens
war und dieses bekenntnis meine damen
und herren ist überfällig
nein die täter kamen nicht aus
deutschland die tat verantwortung für
diese morde
bei den palästinensischen tätern und
deren libyschen helfern es ist sehr
bitter das von heutigen politischen
vertretern dieser länder kein wort der
anteilnahme kein wort des bedauerns
kommt
sie die täter
und ihre helfer waren es acht
palästinensische attentäter und deren
drahtzieher sie waren es die ihren hass
und den terror nach münchen brachten sie
tragen verantwortung für diese tat
damit aber damit sind wir nicht frei
auch wir tragen verantwortung
die verantwortung des gastgebers nicht
verhindert zu haben
was wir hätten verhindern müssen die
verantwortung das leben der geiseln zu
schützen die sich in der gewalt von
terroristen befanden heute
50 jahre später sind doch immer viele
viel zu viele fragen offen
ich spiele gingen damals noch am tag der
trauerfeier weiter
games must geworden und auch die politik
tat alles um so schnell wie möglich zur
tagesordnung überzugehen dem anschlag
folgten jahre und jahrzehnte
des schweigens des verdrängens jahre der
wachsenden gleichgültigkeit gegenüber
dem schicksal der hinterbliebenen jahre
der hartherzigkeit
auch das ist ein versagen
wie konnte das alles geschehen dieser
frage müssen wir uns stellen und nach
antworten suchen und wir müssen diese
antworten endlich finden wollen
warum wurden die überlebenden täter so
schnell abgeschoben und nie juristisch
belangt es ist schwer erträglich dass
sich einer der damaligen täter noch
heute dieses verbrechens rühmt und vor
der kamera versichert dass er wieder
genau so handeln würde
was waren die genauen verbindungen der
täter zu deutschen rechtsextremisten
oder zur auf
warum waren die deutschen
sicherheitskräfte der als schlecht
ausgeführt und überfordert
hat deutschland warnungen aus israel
ignoriert
und warum wurde israelische hilfe bei
der befreiung abgelehnt weshalb wurden
akten jahrzehntelang unter verschluss
gehalten oder gar noch ihre existenz
geleugnet
warum gab es nicht einmal
einen untersuchungsausschuss
meine damen und herren wir reden über
eine große tragödie und ein dreifaches
versagen das erste betrifft die
vorbereitung dieses spiel und das
sicherheitskonzept
das wald umfasst die ereignisse am
fünfter und sechster september 1972 das
dritte versagen beginnt am tag nach dem
attentat das schweigen das drängen das
vergessen
ich begrüße es ausdrücklich dass die
bundesregierung nun die einsetzung einer
israelisch deutschen historiker
kommission vorschlägt ich hoffe dass es
der kommission gelingen wird mehr licht
in dieses dunkle kapitel zu bringen
voraussetzung ist dass sie möglichst
umfassenden zugang zu dokumenten erhält
und dass sie nach kräften in ihrer
arbeit unterstützt wird den experten aus
beiden ländern kommt eine große
verantwortung zu ihrer arbeit wird
vielleicht schmerzhafte unbequeme
wahrheiten zutage fördern
auch zutage fördern müssen aber wir
müssen die geschichte von münchen 72
aufarbeiten und im übrigen auch die
geschichte der nicht aufarbeitung
eine wichtige lehre von münchen 72 ist
wir müssen jede form von antisemitismus
in unserem land von antisemitischen hass
und erst recht von antisemitischer
gewalt
entschieden bekämpfen das ist und bleibt
unsere verantwortung vor der geschichte
eine weitere wichtige lehre wir müssen
als demokratie wehrhaft sein
freiheit und sicherheit sind keine
gegensätze sie bedingen sich gegenseitig
eine freiheitliche gesellschaft kann
sich niemals vollständig schützen vor
terrorangriffen die auf eines zielen die
freiheit nämlich wir müssen wachsam sein
gegenüber den feinden der demokratie den
inneren wie den äußeren denn wir leben
in einer zeit in der die liberalen
demokratien stärke angefochten werden
von innen wie von außen nur noch eine
leere gibt uns münchen 72 auf nur wenn
wir die wahrheit wissen wenn wir uns zu
unseren fehlern und versäumnissen
bekennen kann die wunde die auch unser
rechtsstaat 1972 davon getragen hat kann
diese wunde heilen
liebe gäste aber es geht natürlich nicht
um uns und es recht nicht nicht nur um
uns es geht vor allem um die die damals
ihr leben verloren haben es geht um sie
die angehörigen sie haben ein recht
darauf endlich die wahrheit zu erfahren
endlich antworten auf die fragen zu
erhalten die sie seit jahrzehnten quälen
dazu gehört auch die frage
warum sie mit ihrem leid ihrem schmerz
so lange allein gelassen wurden
45 jahre sollte es dauern bis ein
würdiger ort der erinnerung auf dem
olympia gelände eingerichtet wurde bei
der eröffnung vor fünf jahren waren der
damalige israelische präsident rolf
höfling und auch einige der
hinterbliebenen dabei wir haben
gemeinsam getrauert
uns gemeinsam erinnert aber es sollten
noch einmal fünf jahre vergehen bis zu
einer einigung über eine angemessene
entschädigung
liebe erste liebe angehörige lieber
präsident herzog wir sind vereint dem
stillen andenken an die zwölf menschen
die damals ihr leben verloren haben
wir sind vereint im schmerz aber wir
sollten nicht vergessen es ist
ihr schmerz der schmerz der angehörigen
ist hier schmerz den wir viel zu lange
nicht ausreichend gewürdigt haben und
ich weiß auch
die jetzt gefundene verständigung
wird nicht alle wunden heilen können
ich richte die folgenden worte deshalb
ausdrücklich an sie
deren leben seit 50 jahren von verlust
trauer und schmerz beherrschtes wir
können nicht wiedergutmachen was
geschehen ist
auch nicht was sie an abwehr ignoranz
und unrecht erfahren und erlitten haben
das beschämt nicht
deshalb habe ich vor fünf jahren hier in
münchen um entschuldigung gebeten und
ich füge heute hinzu
ich bitte sie als staatsoberhaupt dieses
landes und dem namen der bundesrepublik
deutschland
um vergebung und vergebung für den
mangelnden schutz der israelischen
athleten
damals bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen
und für die mangelnde aufklärung danach
dafür
das geschehen konnte
was geschehen ist
es ist meine pflicht und mein bedürfnis
unsere deutsche verantwortung zu
bekennen hier und heute und für die
zukunft
möge der heutige tag dazu führen dass
sie die angehörigen
sich wahrgenommen fühlen in ihrem
schmerz
dass sie spüren dass es uns ernst ist
mit unserer verantwortung
meine damen und herren liebe gäste
verehrt der staatspräsident
die freundschaft
die versöhnung die israel uns geschenkt
hat ist
nichts weniger als ein wunder
möge der heutige tag auch dazu führen
dass wir deutsche uns des kostbaren guts
würdig erweisen
das ist die grundlage dieser
freundschaft ist
jenes gut
dass vor 50 jahren an diesem ort so
beschädigt wurde
vertrauen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
angehörige der ermordeten
bundespräsident
steinmeier mein freund story gehen damit
als ganzem herzen für ihre mutige
historische rede die all unsere herzen
berührt
theater ministerpräsident des freistaats
bayern muss
geschätzte persönlichkeiten des
öffentlichen lebens in deutschland
geschlossen
all diejenigen die das fangen wir denken
an die ermordeten werte gäste
mama warum
dauert mein leiden jährige und ist meine
hunde so bösartig dass sie nicht heilen
heute
bleibt ein immerwährender
diese schreckliche eine nicht teilen
wollen
die winzerin stunden
unendliche
widersprüchlich
die alle paar stunden aus dem
olympischen dorf in münchen zusammen wir
konnten nicht fassen dass sportler
schiedsrichter und trainer habe juden
und israelis also kaufe deutschem boden
von terroristen festgehalten werden wie
sehr hatten wir uns einen anderen
auswahl
herzenswunsch erfüllt unsere herzen
wurden gebrochen unsere hormone
zerschlagen 23 stunden später haben wir
die schlimmstmögliche nachricht sogar
einer von hundert überlebt
ich war ein kleiner junge
doch werde ich in der schrecklichen
morgen nie vergessen als ich zusammen
mit meinem vater ein schiff zur schule
vor und im auto hören wir mit
angehaltenem atem die schrecklichen
erreichen moni werde ich den tränen
vergessen die sich in unseren augen sein
um das gefühl des totalen jobs die
trauer der
schmerz
und ein ganzes land
so genannten heiteren olympischen spiele
sie von den organisatoren genannt wurden
mit einem mal zum tiefsten und befinden
moment in der geschichte des
internationalen sports und olympischen
spielen
die elf wochen sportler und seligen
angedenkens die opfer des massakers in
münchen vor 50 jahren im namen des board
geistes zu den olympischen spielen
namen des geistes der olympischen
bewegung
der gemeinschafts kameradschaft und
freundschaft
zusammenhalt und gesellschaftlicher
solidarität zwischen ländern zwischen
nationen sie wurden
[Musik]
grausam
dass das leben von episodischen spotten
unter einem deutschen polizeibeamten
aber in der menschliche tragödie wird in
wien moral und gerechtigkeit waren
zerschlagen die würde des ein schlimmes
erachtet wurden menschlichkeit verloren
gegangen dies war der moment an dem die
olympische fackel erloschen für uns
ist dieses nationale
olympische einheit und solidarität
ihren waren mit blut
mit den fünf olympischen ringen wird nie
wieder die selbe sein jahrzehntelanges
unter nationale olympische komitee das
gedenken
unterlassen zum rhein und dem schmerz
der familien der opfer lag über den
verlust ihrer lieben zu ihrer qualen und
die
[Musik]
gleichgültigkeit
über das im stich gelassen
sie hat eine simple invest
grasen sie sein die da lautet dieses mal
werden muss deren lehrern in jeder
generation gelernt werden sollten eine
tragödie die uns immer dafür dass es bei
den größeren
willen doch das ist kein größerer ersten
satz im flur den sportgeist gibt
auch nicht vergessen bei den olympischen
spielen
1972 was faul die welt darf nicht
vergessen mit rabatten den kampf gegen
den terror vakuum überall und jederzeit
wie gemeinsam entschlossen und mit
nachdruck geführt werden muss
menschlicher gesellschaft
anpassen drei wohnungen hier
bei gleichzeitiger beurteilung und
bekämpfung des bösen des antisemitismus
des hauses und des terrors in diesem
sinn aber nicht nur in diesem sinn ist
deutschlands entscheidung der letzten
noch einmal meinen guten freund dem
bundespräsidenten frank walter schneider
und damit für seinen grossen
anstrengungen und natürlich dienen auch
der bundesregierung regierung des
freistaates und der stadt münchen danke
ich für die federführung die
entscheidung hob antworten für die
massen und das ohne
vorher zu übernehmen für nichtmitglieder
objektive fundierte untersuchung zu
ermöglichen oder die
familien 7 zu entschädigen es ist fast
ein halbes jahrhundert verstrichen habe
dies ist ein wichtiger moralischer
gerechter schräg gegenüber den opfern
den familien und der geschichte fertig
ist im hebräischen gibt es ein ganz
besonderes jahr für menschen die durch
ein unglück ums leben kamen oder
ermordet worden so jemand wird karin an
ball und dasselbe wort alleine meint
auch im hebräischen einen leeren raum
etwas fehlen
jeder der elf al alimi von münchen war
eine welt für seine wie er dafür seine
und für seine geliebten jeder waren
keine worte
zu trösten geschätzte angerückten neuer
mode
bereiten am weiterleben die
folgegeneration
auf diese art erinnern
werdet mir lassen sie uns die erinnerung
an die opfer des massakers der münchner
olympischen spiele für immer in unseren
herzen der waren
[Applaus]
bewegen den worten des israelischen
präsidenten hätten wir noch einmal an
das leid der hinterbliebenen
erinnert konnte ich noch ein paar mal
mit deutschlands bundespräsident
steinmeier die zeigt dass er die
umfassende entschuldigung die steinmeier
ausgesprochen hat denn gleichzeitig auch
die einsetzung einer deutsch
israelischen historiker kommission
ankündigte sehr schätzt
[Musik]
ja
schütte
[Musik]
schön
naja
[Musik]
war schön
die stadt
[Musik]
da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum warten
dito
[Musik]
zur gedenkveranstaltung für die opfer
des olympiateams vor 50 jahren konnten
sich interessierte bürgerinnen und
bürger aus dem landkreis anmelden
jetzt folgt die rede von
bundesministerin nancy faeser
angehörige und stellvertretend für alle
liebe an die spitze
meine damen und herren abgeordnete des
deutschen bundestages des bayerischen
landtags an der spitze frau
landtagspräsidentin ilse aigner sehr
geehrter herr ministerpräsident dr söder
sehr geehrter herr präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes herr dr
herbert sehr geehrter herr dr schuster
und sehr geehrte frau dr knobloch schön
dass sie heute gekommen sind
meine damen und herren was werden es für
gefühle gewesen sein mit denen sich die
delegation des staates israel im jahr
1972 auf die reise nach deutschland
gemacht haben
eine reise in das land der täter keine
30 jahre nach dem ende des krieges
keine 30 jahre nach dem holocaust
keine stunde
wenn dir dieser millionenfache schmerz
nicht jeden tag das leben überschattet
hätte
nun einreise nach deutschland als
menschen denen das herz für den sport
schlägt die sich jahrelang vorbereitet
haben die sich in frieden mit anderen
nationen messen wollen ich versuche mir
vorzustellen
mit welcher mischung aus trauer gedenken
an spannung und vorfreude sie in unser
land gereist sind
olympische spiele wollen welt
veranstaltungen für das friedliche
miteinander der völker
hier geht es um fairen wettkampf um
höher schneller weiter ohne ansehen der
person ihrer herkunft ihrer geschichte
wir sprechen vom olympischen frieden mit
seinem ziehen dass alle athleten
künstler und familien in sicherheit
anreisen die wettkämpfe miterleben und
ebenso sicher wieder abreisen können
dieser olympische frieden wurde von
palästinensischen terroristen jäh
zerstört und seitdem liegt darüber ein
dunkler schatten
bis zu diesem tag wollten wir als gute
gastgeber unseren beitrag leisten die
welt bei uns willkommen zu heißen wie
wichtig war es dass die mannschaft aus
israel der einladung gefolgt war dass
wir sie bei uns begrüßen durften
unser land stand aber nicht nur in der
pflicht sie zu begrüßen wir standen auch
in der pflicht sie zu schützen
an dieser verantwortung sind wir auf
schreckliche art und weise gescheitert
wir haben der israelischen mannschaft im
olympischen dorf nicht im ansatz den
schutz gegeben der notwendig und
angemessen gewesen wäre und wir hatten
damals weder die richtigen noch
ausreichend ausgebildete kräfte um sie
aus den händen der geiselnehmer zu
befreien
der bundespräsident hat in seiner rede
von einem dreifachen versagen gesprochen
als bundesministerin des inneren nehme
ich diese worte nicht nur sehr ernst
sondern ich möchte mich im namen der
bundesregierung auch dafür entschuldigen
nun muss umfassend geklärt werden was zu
klären ist die vollständige aufarbeitung
dieses anschlages und deutschlands rolle
darin zu fordern ist nicht nur das
unabdingbare recht der angehörigen und
betroffenen es ist die pflicht der
bundesrepublik deutschland dies zu tun
und es ist in der tat beschämend dass
die aufarbeitung nicht längst erfolgt
ist mir ist es deswegen ganz besonders
wichtig eine unabhängige kommission aus
deutschen und israel zwischen
historikerinnen und historiker nein zu
setzen womit der weiteren aufarbeitung
zu beauftragen endlich muss die seit
jahrzehnten berechtigte kritik der
opferfamilien und der wissenschaft
konsequenzen haben
ich will gerade als innenministerin hier
in fürstenfeldbruck daran erinnern dass
dieses attentat der traurige anlass
wurde unser system der inneren
sicherheit grundlegend neu aufzustellen
wir haben eine spezialeinheit gsg 9 der
grenzschutztruppe gegründet die es bis
heute bei der bundespolizei gibt und die
national wie international höchstes
ansehen genießt auch allen bundesländern
stellten danach
spezialeinsatzkommandos auf um in der
fläche präsent zu sein und mehr noch die
deutschen und israelischen
spezialeinheiten gsg 9 und jammern haben
inzwischen ein über jahrzehnte
aufgebautes sehr enges verhältnis
zueinander wir lernen gemeinsam und
tauschen uns auf vielen ebenen aus was
für ein geschenk nach diesen
schrecklichen ereignissen und ich finde
es war eine tolle geste von man und der
gsg 9
anlässlich des heutigen gedenkens einen
gemeinsamen absprung aus einem
hubschrauber zu machen und jeweils die
deutschen und die israelische flagge
dabei zu wissen
dass sie ihr präsident herzog und sie
die angehörigen der familien heute hier
sind erfüllt mich mit großer dankbarkeit
wir können einen neuen anfang wagen sie
reichen uns die hände und wir dürfen
diese ergreifen
im gedenken an jeden einzelnen ihrer
männer väter großväter und
familienmitglieder die ihr leben lassen
mussten und in verantwortung für eine
welt in der dem terror überall und jeder
form entgegengetreten werden muss ganz
israel und sie die heute zu uns gekommen
sind kennen die tägliche gefahr wäre
begegnen will der braucht kraft
entschlossenheit und stärke die bekommen
wir aber nur wenn wir zusammenstehen
wenn wir möglichst genau wissen wer und
was uns bedroht reden und erinnern ist
gut und notwendig konsequentes handeln
gehört aber auch dazu die
deutsch-israelische
sicherheitskooperation ist eng und von
großem vertrauen geprägt
davon konnte ich mich vor einigen
monaten selbst überzeugen als ich in
israel zu gast war und ich danke meinen
kollegen um mehr bei lev ausdrücklich
dafür dass er auch heute hier ist
wir haben viele gemeinsame projektes
werden viele hinzukommen
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und ich werde
mich mit aller kraft dafür einsetzen
nach dem holocaust steht der fünfte
september
1972 auch für unsere pflicht die
jüdinnen und juden in unserem land
wirksam zu schützen
jeder angriff ist einer zu viel und
trifft unsere gesellschaft bis ins mark
wir können und werden den antisemitismus
in worten oder taten niemals zulassen
und wir werden ihm weiterhin mit aller
entschiedenheit entgegentreten meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]
dazu gehört das erinnern und das
aufklären und dazu gehört die kraft
eines staates dass seine schuld und
seine fehler der vergangenheit bekennt
und genau das tun wir heute und dazu
gehört natürlich auch das handeln in der
zukunft mein respekt und mein dank gilt
allen vertreterin vertretern angehörigen
aus israel die heute zu uns gekommen
sind um gemeinsam zu gedenken es ist ein
zeichen der mahnung und der freundschaft
und wir wollen heute
heute der 12 brutal ermordeten menschen
erinnern unsere deutsche verantwortung
endet nie
dieses gedenken ist ein teil davon und
soll uns gemeinsam auf den weg in eine
zukunft lenken der wir ein starkes
zeichen gegen gewalt und terror setzen
und ein zeichen von respekt und
freundschaft in einer welt die den
frieden gerade dieser tage nötiger
braucht denn je vielen dank
auch die bundes innenministerin so
knüpft ihre entschuldigung
mit der forderung in zukunft gegen jede
art von konservatismus und terror zu
kämpfen
nach ihr spricht thomas bach präsident
des internationalen olympischen komitees
der familie software victims
bundespräsident fischer
ministerpräsident exzellenz sehr geehrte
damen und herren
der fünfte september
1972 ist der dunkelste tag der
olympischen geschichte
was so friedlich und fröhlich begann
endete in unfassbaren leid
wir teilen den schmerz der angehörigen
der elf israelischen opfer und des
deutschen polizisten
bis heute
erfüllt uns diese barbarische eingriff
mit entsetzen und abscheu und
doch
vermag unserer hand teilnahme kaum den
schmerz der familien zu lindern die
ihren sohn
bruder vater ihren beliebten ehepartnern
die liebe ihres lebens
durch dieses feige attentat verloren
haben
dieser schmerz
ist um so tiefer weil
ihre lieben ihr leben
bei olympischen spielen verloren haben
sie hatten ihre teilnahme an diesem
friedlichen wettstreit mit den athleten
aus der ganzen welt so sehr ersehnte
der sinn
olympischer spiele ist eine friedvolle
feier
der menschlichen einheit in allen
unserer vielfalt
ungeachtet aller politischen oder
kulturellen differenzen
deshalb war dieses attentat auch ein
anschlag auf die olympischen spiele und
die olympischen werte
die gemeinsame schweigeminute mit
hunderten millionen von menschen aus der
ganzen welt
während der eröffnungsfeier der
olympischen spiele tokio 2020 machte
dies auf bewegende art deutlich
auch heute
verneigen wir uns in ehrenden gedenken
und tiefem respekt vor den opfern
wir fühlen mit den angehörigen
wir teilen ihre trauer
die ermordeten mitglieder der
israelischen olympiamannschaft
waren
sind und bleiben teil unserer
olympischen gemeinschaft
trotz dieses schrecklichen verlustes
haben weder die angehörigen noch das
nationale olympische komitee von israel
den olympischen spielen den rücken
gekehrt
israelische athletinnen und athleten
haben dennoch an allen darauffolgenden
olympischen spielen teilgenommen
mein dank gilt daher insbesondere an die
spitze und elena roman
und allen angehörigen
sowie dem nationalen olympischen komitee
von israel hier vertreten durch seine
präsidentin nayla rat
sie haben uns immer die hand gereicht
und damit die würdigen gedenken in rio
2016 und tokio 2020 ermöglicht
dafür sind wir ihnen für immer dankbar
dort
läuft dort hinein
raptor dort family members
kraft oder
osi office
bei
topnews offert
judith lotz als der schmerz den sie
erlitten haben haben sie
den rücken zugewandt making
in
ihre hände gereicht um diese würdigen
momente der erinnerung bei den anderen
fischen spielen zu ermöglichen
dafür sind wir eine zeremonie format ist
50 jahre trauer schmerz
zweifel und unsicherheit vergessen zu
machen
in dieser allzu langen zeit
ist vieles im dunkeln geblieben
wir dürfen es nicht zulassen dass
dieser dunkelheit
nun vergessen und gleichgültigkeit vor
deshalb begrüßen wir dass eine
unabhängige kommission
volles licht in das dunkel des handelns
staatlicher stellen werfen sein
wenn und soweit wird zu dieser
aufklärung mit informationen beitragen
können werden wir dies tun
die olympischen spiele
vereinen die gesamte welt in
friedlichen wettbewerb
deshalb kommt unsere heutigen
gedenkfeier
eine noch tiefere bedeutung zu
wir stehen zusammen
vereint in unserem gedenken
vereint aber auch in unserem bekenntnis
zur friedensmission der olympischen
spiele
wir zeigen damit dass die werte die
werte der menschlichen solidarität
und des friedens
stärker sind als alle kräfte des hasses
und der spaltung
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ioc-präsident ich vom dunkelsten tag in
der geschichte der olympischen spiele
und bedankte sich gleichzeitig bei den
angehörigen der opfer dass sie sich nie
vom olympischen gedanken abgewanderten
es folgt der präsident des zentralrats
der juden in deutschland josef schuster
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
steinmeier sehr geehrter herr
staatspräsident herzog herr
ministerpräsident dr
von landtagspräsidentin eigener frau
bundesinnenministerium feser liebe frau
knobloch vor allen dingen sehr geehrte
angehörige der grausamen hier in
fürstenfeldbruck bzw münchen ermordete
an der spitze frau spitze
ich erinnere mich gut an den september
1972 einer meiner prägendsten
erinnerungen ist dabei eine begegnung
mit kaffee und kuchen
den ersten septembertagen
1972 waren einige der israelische
sportler zu besuch in meiner
heimatgemeinde würzburg gewesen ich saß
als damals 18-jähriger mit ihnen am
tisch genoss den kuchen und das
olympische fieber
es hätte eine wunderbare begegnung aus
jugendtagen so in erinnerung bleiben
können doch es kam anders nur wenige
tage schmeckt späte schmeckte die
erinnerung an den kaffee und kuchen
schal
einige menschen die eben noch neben mir
gesessen hatten waren nun tot ermordet
hier in festen fürstenfeldbruck
beziehungsweise münchen nachdem sie
zuvor auf grausame weise von
palästinensischen terroristen in
geiselhaft gehalten worden war der
versuch der geiselbefreiung
meint vollkommener fehlschlag die
schüsse und explosionen
hier in fürstenfeldbruck waren bis weit
in die stadtmitte zu hörbar wie einer
meiner mitarbeiter der hier aus
fürstenfeldbruck kommt aus den
erzählungen seiner verwandtschaft
berichtete
david marx berger chef friedmann josef
gutfreund eliza hall
fiorano mit ihrer show martins lavigne
andere spitze jakob springer moschee
weinberg und der polizist anton flieger
bauer starben mal die
sicherheitsbehörden man muss klar sagen
auf allen ebenen versagten es ist
zynisch die bundesrepublik war sehr
bemüht ein anderes gesicht als das von
1936 zu zeigen doch am ende waren die
spieler die so heiter begonnen für juden
am ende wieder unerträglich düster
27 jahre nach der shoah die einige der
ermordeten bzw deren eltern noch
überlebt hatten gab es wieder ein
massaker an juden auf deutschem boden
diesmal nicht ausgeführt von nazis
sondern von fanatischen palästinensern
1972 war bei nicht dabei nicht der erste
terroranschlag gewesen der israelis zum
ziel hatte seit 1968 hatte es diverse
attentate vor allem auf el al maschine
gegeben bis 1970 befanden sich
zwischenzeitlich
750 passagiere aus westlichen ländern in
den hand palästinensischer terroristen
und trotzdem konnten oder wollten die
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden die
israelische mannschaft nicht besser
schützen
vielleicht auch weil sich niemand die
wirkmacht des antisemitismus vorstellen
konnte eine wirkmacht so stark dass die
neonazis raf-terroristen und
palästinenser dazu brachte gegen das
gemeinsame feindbild juden zur gruppe zu
kooperieren
in diesem zusammenhang finde ich es
unerträglich dass bei der documenta 5 10
kassel noch bis zum 25 september dieser
mörderischen hass auf juden bei den
tokio reels ungefiltert und affirmativ
reproduziert wird die macher
[Applaus]
die macher lassen propagandamaterial
linker und palästinensischer
terrororganisationen
unkommentiert in dauerschleife laufen
insofern sollte man nicht unbedingt
glauben dass man heute durchgehend viel
weiter ist in der beurteilung von
antisemitismus wie genau es zu dem
attentat kommen konnte wird wohl in
gänze nie geklärt werden können dass die
deutschen behörden in sachen transparenz
transparenz ein weiteres unrühmliches
kapitel schreiben schrieben gehört zur
wahrheit dazu anstatt für aufklärung zu
sorgen dokumente und archive freizugeben
er schloss man sich die verantwortlichen
zu vertuschen und zu mauern dass die
politische führung der palästinenser die
in teilen noch ihre wurzeln im
terrorismus hat dies bisher sich bis
heute nicht von dem attentat distanziert
steht auf der anderen seite ich freue
mich sehr dass sie die hinterbliebenen
trotz allem doch noch zu der heutigen
zeremonie gekommen sind diese einigung
ist ein wichtiges zeichen
die fehler und unzulänglichkeiten die
von deutscher seite aus gemacht wurden
können und sollen nicht vergessen werden
aber es ist anzuerkennen dass sich
politisch verantwortlichen der gegenwart
der verantwortung und den fehlern der
vergangenheit gestellt haben dass wir
hier und heute gemeinsam denken dies
stimmt mich hoffnungsvoll
ich danke wir aufmerksamkeit
der präsident des zentralrats der juden
schuster freut sich darüber dass es doch
noch zu einer einigung gekommen ist und
viel zwischenapplaus war sehr
anprangerte dass bei der documenta in
kassel heute noch antisemitismus
ungefiltert verbreitet werde
münchen
[Musik]
china
also
nicht darin schon
[Musik]
ich war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wien
münchen
[Musik]
nicht
bestehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fr
[Musik]
wir hören jetzt das grußwort von
charlotte knobloch der präsidentin der
israelitischen kultusgemeinde münchen
und oberbayern
wer nicht dabei war und nicht
was das
1972 für eine stimmung war
seit jahren hatte sich münchen auf die
spiele vorbereitet die freude war mit
händen zu greifen
unbändige freude auf die heiteren spiele
die zweite chance das große comeback
deutschlands auf der weltbühne als
friedlicher freiheitlich
demokratischer staat der die welt
willkommen heißt
das glück war vor
14 tagen
am elften tag haben die
palästinensischen terroristen das leben
der israelischen sportler und ihre
familien zertrümmert
das leben von anton flieger bauer und
seiner familie
und sie zerschlugen den traum
von olympia
der albtraum des elften tages
er dauerte an
für die hinterbliebenen
staates israel die jüdische gemeinschaft
es dauerte dann letztlich bis vor
wenigen tagen
es ist gut so
dass wir heute hier alle zusammen
entwürfe in einheit gemeinsam gedenken
gartner sehen mit den atisreal mal
herzog
der wert der bundespräsident steinmeier
sehr verehrter herr präsident dr
frau bundesministerin feser sehr
geehrter herr ministerpräsident dr
sehr geehrter herr ministerpräsident
söder sehr geehrter herr präsident dr
schuster
verehrter herr landrat kammern sehen
meine damen und herren
die erde victims families und bhf auf
die typisch community sehr sind die
damen und herren und im namen der
jüdischen gemeinde hier immer sehr
dankbar dafür dass ich kein flieger bei
niedermeyer
die erinnerung an einen 5 972 sind auch
bei mir noch sehr präsent
meine tochter war als hostess im
olympischen dorf
auch sie hatte am morgen
6 uhr voll euphorie die wohnung
verlassen
und kam am abend als halber mensch
zurück
aber sie kam nach hause gott sei dank
elf männer väter brüder warm als
sportler nach münchen gekommen
und kehrten in särgen nach israel zurück
der schmerz ihrer familien ist in all
den jahren nicht milder geworden
weil die wunden nicht heilen konnten
weil demut im wege stand
verzweiflung und frustration
auf die tödliche befreiungsaktion
folgte die fortsetzung der spiele die
kaltherzigkeit von brandis die stete
verweigerung olympische funktionieren
dem attentat auf die olympische bewegung
angemessen zu gedenken und auch in
deutschland blieb die aufarbeitung des
anschlags und seinen erfolgen sowie der
umgang mit den hinterbliebenen hinter
den erwartungen zurück
eine sehr lange zeit die
ist nun zu ende
ich danke allen beteiligten
insbesondere auch auf seiten der
deutschen politik sie haben ohne jede
einflussmöglichkeit auf die ereignisse
von damals heute verantwortung
übernommen für
die heilung
der alten kunst
meine damen und herren wir alle nie alle
münchnerinnen und münchner wir alle habe
ich die europameisterschaft im august
genossen auch verstehe ich dass münchen
die spiele von 72 und den olympiapark
feiert und doch
mir scheint einiges ist nie ganz bewusst
geworden
wie sehr wie nachhaltig das attentat am
elften tag ins herz der israelis und der
jüdischen gemeinschaft in deutschland
eingeschlagen hat der schock dass nur
wenige jahrzehnte nach der shoa und nach
der schwierigen entscheidung
in diesem land zu bleiben
hier wieder juden ermordet werden war
unfassbar groß
bis heute
denken über ist es so wichtig diese
empathie zu spüren die heute
allgegenwärtig ist das gemeinsame
verständnis die übernommene
verantwortung
das ist die richtige antwort auf die
jahrelanges vergessen machen verdrängen
ignorieren
meine damen und herren ich wünsche mir
dass wir uns diese entschlossenheit zur
verantwortung der waren für die
erinnerung an die toten und
für das handeln an die leben
für die erinnerung ist in den letzten
jahren viel getan worden es gilt ein
großer dank der staatsregierung dem bund
dem ioc und speziell ludwig spaenle für
den einschnitt im olympiapark
und ich werde mir auch einen dauerhaften
würdigen gedenkort hier am fliegerhorst
für die wünschen wo herr landrat kann
man sehen sich seit jahren in
bemerkenswerter weise um das gedenken
verdient macht
und die verantwortung für die lebenden
wir alle wissen was zu tun ist wir
müssen den wachsenden hass gegen juden
eindämmen in konsequent in allen formen
benennen und bekämpfen auch und gerade
dann wenn er als sogenannte israelkritik
ankommt und doch nichts anderes ist als
uralter antisemitismus in seiner
äußersten form bedroht er uns als
derselbe terror der vor 50 jahren hier
zwölf leben auslöschte er bedroht uns
noch heute in israel in deutschland in
aller welt
der terror ist derselbe aber wir sind
besser geworden wer hafte der hass wird
nie wieder gewinnen im gegenteil und
weil das meine überzeugung ist und weil
ich nach wie vor und trotz allem an das
gute und das beste glauben
wünsche ich mir
dass die heutigen generationen noch
einmal die chance haben olympia zu
spüren und zu leben im eigenen land ich
wünsche mir dass am lebens am liebsten
in münchen
die jungen menschen verdienen
die junge menschen wo immer sie auch
sind
verdienen es diese freude zu spüren die
hoffnung und das glück stand
sie sei trotz allem optimistisch
geblieben sagt charlotte knobloch selbst
seine holocaust überlebende und wünscht
sich noch einmal olympische spiele in
münchen
damit die jüngere generation die
leichtigkeit erleben können sie sagt
aber auch der schmerz der angehörigen
seien all den jahren nicht weniger
geworden weil die wunden nicht heilen
konnten weil die wut im wege stand nun
thomas karmasin landrat des landkreises
fürstenfeldbruck
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
exzellenz und liebe frau spitze over
ehrte ehrengäste meine damen und herren
ich
danke ihnen allen herzlich für ihr
kommen und für ihre worte
sie haben dem auszug und bedeutung
verliehen was uns hier in
fürstenfeldbruck vor ort seit vielen
jahrzehnten wichtig ist
die erinnerung an die opfer und das
mitgefühl mit den angehörigen
ich freue mich deshalb besonders dass
sie heute mit dabei sind verehrte
angehörige und was die veranstaltung
nicht von gefühlen der enttäuschung
überschattet werden muss
wir menschen vor ort sitzen auf den
zuschauerrängen der geschichte nicht auf
der bühne der die sie gestalten
wir haben gejubelt als eine israelische
mannschaft ein deutscher stadion
eingezogen ist
als die welt getrauert hatte über die
jungen sportler die als unsere gäste ihr
leben verloren haben
haben wir geweint als
die wettkämpfe sich fortgesetzt wurden
sind wir ohnmächtig zurückgeblieben denn
unsere
olympischen spiele waren vorbei
geblieben ist unser bemühen unsere
trauer fruchtbar zu machen für eine
erinnerungsarbeit
dem spontanen gedenken der menschen am
jahrestag hat der landkreis seit 1997
einen rahmen gegeben
die erinnerung hat gestalt angenommen in
form einer durch den künstler hannes
goetz gestalteten gedenkstätte
und wir haben die letzten jahre genutzt
um mit unterstützung von sponsoren einen
virtuellen de erinnerungsort in form
einer website und eine app zu entwickeln
der die ereignisse weltweit und in
mehreren sprachen erfahrbar macht und so
ohne aufwand jedem und jeder
information und erinnerung ermöglicht
diesen digitalen erinnerungsort stellen
wir später in einer eigenen
pressekonferenz vor
zu wort kommen darin auch zeitzeugen
deren eindrücke wie auf diese weise für
die nachwelt erhalten konnten
was uns für die zukunft bleibt ist die
hoffnung
dass die bundesrepublik nach dem abzug
der bundeswehr das gebäude des towers
zur verfügung stellt damit wir am
originalschauplatz der erinnerung raum
geben können
wir erneuern an dieser stelle unser
versprechen dass wir vor zehn jahren
gegeben haben und dass wir auch gehalten
haben
wenn alle ehrengäste wieder weg sind
und sich die aufmerksamkeit der medien
wieder auf anderes wichtig wenn es
wieder still wird hier am ort des
geschehens
wir bleiben da jahr für jahr ich danke
den antrag
das festival thomas karmasin
kündigte einen digitalen erinnerungsort
an und wünscht sich am liebsten künftig
ein erinnerungsort im alten tower was ja
auch schon charlotte knobloch die
präsidentin der israelitischen
kultusgemeinde münchen und oberbayern
angeregt hatte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf die folgende rede dass alle hier
anwesenden mit großer spannung gewartet
haben anke spitze die witwe des trainers
andre spitze wird nun zuletzt reden sie
ist so eine art inoffiziellen sprecherin
der hinterbliebenen geworden die bis
zuletzt um kompensationszahlungen
gerungen hat
bei dir ist andere 50
stunden nach dem essen habe ich in
deinem zimmer gestanden ich glaube
in diesem land
und ich dachte
ich werde nie aufhören darüber zu lesen
sind deshalb und es nie nie wieder
passieren
das sind diejenigen der öffentlich waren
ein preislevel seine vergebung mir bitte
an dreht das ist so lange
auf diesen endlich nach 50 m haben hier
so viel erreichen
schließlich aber schließlich und endlich
bedeutet bist du immer noch weg und das
ändert nichts daran sie haben sich
umgebracht und damit auch ein teil von
mir und armani tal der liebe dich
geliebt haben siemens ambra haben unsere
hoffnung unsere träume unserer zukunft
ermordet aber sie haben nicht meine
liebe für dich und du warst so und
freundlich sind
liebevoll animiert wurde ja so wie wir
waren damals nur
zwei jahre verheiratet aber das war der
schönste zeit meines lebens nicht alles
wir hatten einander wir hatten ein
kleines mädchen riegel ist nun unser
baby von damals ist heute kein baby mehr
anouk ist jetzt eine schöne glamorous
zur seite empfindsamer auto war so stolz
auf mich immer noch daran wie
du hat gelacht und geweint hast als sie
geboren wurde allerhand gefasst
und es bricht
sie nicht kennen gelernt hast
glücklich wer so mit einem meinen acht
enkel und wie traurig ist es nur dass
diese enkel dich nie kennengelernt haben
aber es gibt noch etwas sagt dass ich
sehr stolz bin ich habe meine kinder
ohne hass aufgezogen ohne hass in ihren
händen sind genauso wie du es gewollt
hätte ist dass ich es und es tut mir
auch sehr leid desto elan anläuft mich
kennst mein partner ist der letzten 50
jahre ohne sie wäre ich heute nicht hier
unser weg war lang im gesamten wird aber
wenig an dich denken die sind fast 30
jahre alt mit deinen hilfs und füßen
zusammengebunden gegen seinen mördern
ausgeliefert und das gibt immer wieder
die motivation weiterzumachen
sprecher der deutschen regierung von
dorfers kanada alaska hatte um
mitternacht von
unglücklich unterbrechung der spiele
gesprochen die nach einigen wochen
vergessen werden würde über schneiders
wir haben das nicht vergessen wir haben
diese unglückliche unterbrechung nach
ein paar wochen nicht vergessen juno
andere düfte wahr ist dass ich mir
selbst ein neues leben aufzubauen habe
und ich bin sicher dass das genau das
ist was für mich wollte ist aber ich
habe keine flügel gefunden die
gerechtigkeit gerechtigkeit nur nicht
wenn sie es vor so und so und deine
teamkameraden haben du hast so sehr
verdient will weiterhin das mächtige
deutschland wirklich alles im sande
titan hätte nicht noch mehr jüdisches
ortrud zudem schon wieder blutige punkt
hinzuzufügen aber jeder wie für fracht
jetzt hoffe ich jetzt einen abschluss
finden kann sie verstehen nicht dass
moniz ist capitoni abschließen kann das
loch in meinem herz wird nie heilen
vielen dank an meinen dank andre für ein
geschenk der liebe ich bin so glücklich
dass ich mit so ein glück dass ich dich
getroffen habe ich du kannst jetzt in
frieden ruhen und das kann ich jetzt
auch wieder
du bist
die stunden
nicht trauern wir werden
was der winter mein flügeln vielen dank
was für eine persönliche rede an die
spitze die witwe des trainers andre
spitze verliest einen brief an ihren
mann und erhält dafür standing ovations
jetzt eine schweigeminute für die opfer
aber
noch applaus frank i die gesagt hat sie
werden nie wirklich zur ruhe kommen
können aber
ihr mann solle trotzdem jetzt in frieden
[Musik]
david berger
anton flieger bauer
friedman
josef gutfreund
leser ralf ihn
josef romano
amicitia
die hat schaaf
marx lavigne
an drei spitzen
jaakov springer
moshe weinberg
[Musik]
spuren
juni
[Musik]
berlin
am
ein
[Musik]
israeli
münchen man ja
nie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
louis
[Musik]
gemen uha
die schmutter
[Musik]
g
zum abschluss der veranstaltung die
hymne von bayern die israelische
nationalhymne hartig war die hoffnung
und die deutsche nationalhymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war der gedenkakt für die opfer des
olympia massakers vor 50 jahren mit
einer klaren übernahme der verantwortung
von deutscher seite auch der zusage dass
eine history eine historikerkommission
eingesetzt werden soll jüdische
israelische und deutsche historiker und
historikerinnen gemeinsam und aber auch
die mahnung das ist so etwas nie wieder
geben darf schön dass sie dabei waren